[Music]
so I'll be extremely brief I have the
honor and pleasure of working with a lot
of smart students researchers and other
folks in the position I have so I get to
introduce all of them and I will just
jump up in between each one so if you're
playing Civic media bingo
now is the time to play you will win
very quickly there's a lot of cool
projects touching a lot of things that I
know people in the room are interested
in so we're going to get started with
Nathan matheus who is now a PhD student
here in Center for Civic media Nathan hi
I'm Nathan and I do data analysis design
and experiments on cooperation online
and I'll be sharing news pad a project
that I started at Microsoft Research and
eventful which my colleagues colleagues
carried on and both of these projects
are related to this idea that sign up
views of building community through
reporting imagine the attention curve of
news online all the way from Kim and
Kanye to an individual tweet we know
that news organizations and Wikipedia
can cover the left end of the curve
really well and that curation tools can
cover stories that at least have a few
tweets about them but there's a huge
need for work and tools that support
things that haven't yet been tweeted
about and things in the middle of that
curve things like the Capitol Hill a
garage sale this profoundly important
community building event in Seattle that
doesn't really get reported by the
mainstream news even in Seattle to start
out Shelley Farnham and Emma Spiro did
developed new algorithms for detecting
community and neighborhood based Twitter
activity and looked at the different
shapes and structure of networks in
different communities to find ways to
help people collaboratively create news
we know that cooperative systems like
wiki news can help at the left end of
the carrot curve but curation tools are
tend tend to be single user and aren't
very collaborative which is where we
came up with the idea for news pad
imagine once an event happens maybe
there's some sparse media someone
creates a news pad post that anyone can
read and edit live people
also recruit others to contribute to
this post and important sites within the
community can embed the article and the
editing tools into the different parts
of the community to create a positive
feedback loop that brings more readers
and more contributors to the post here's
how it works we help novice creators
create a news article by helping them
generate a listicle style news title and
then structure their article in a way
that's easy to contribute to we also
structure participation by inviting
contributors to list their names take
concrete tasks like ask for improvements
offer to help read the article and we
axe ask people to check in to the
article to say they're willing to help
even if they're not sure how yet and
then using social recruitment we have
every single section in the article
linked to the ability to ask your
friends on Twitter or ask people via
email to contribute to the article over
the last summer we started with small
prototypes using actual print cards in
the neighborhood and then moved on to
cover a wide variety of events in
Seattle and elsewhere including last
year's Civic media conference building
on this idea news pad really had the
idea of trying to streamline the
recruitment and collaborative editing
process Andres and Elena designed a
system to structure different tasks that
people can take to contribute to a new
story so they broke individual stories
into concrete tasks that different
people can complete the idea is that you
can you go to eventful request an event
to be covered to say what type it is how
long it's going to last it will then
create a checklist of different tasks
that are need to be completely completed
to write the story those tasks can be
send to community members by your
community mailing list and they can also
be sent to TaskRabbit
using dynamically allocated labour pools
to fill in the gaps
so the TaskRabbit errs go to the event
they have a checklist of things they
need to do interview people get
information take video that's then
passed to a curator who looks at the
tasks approves of the work sends more
tasks back as the story evolves and then
puts it into the story
here's a screenshot of the system which
you can see now an eventful that gives
people a mission-based view of the tasks
they need as a group to write the story
and then that story can be fed into
systems like news pad into a common
story and shared back out to the
community in that positive feedback loop
that I described previously news pad has
been open sourced by Microsoft and I'm
doing ongoing work on it and you can
contact andreas and Elena for more
information about their projects
thanks thanks Nathan if you want to
think about how to make your projects
more collaborative talk to Nathan he's
an expert at that so next up we have
Katherine dick nausea who I've had the
pleasure of working with over the last
couple years Katherine hi I'm back
so if journalism is based on the who
where when why how I have been working
on the where of the news for the past
couple years at the Center for civic
media so one really exciting
announcement I have to make is that
Rahul Bhargav and I have recent released
recently released a technology called
cliff which is an open-source geo
parsing technology and it's called cliff
because it's based on a technology
called Clavin
so you might be like what's Geo parsing
so geo parsing is the process of
extracting place data from unstructured
text like news articles what that helps
us do is look at news stories at scale
and come to conclusions about long-term
patterns trends and biases and media
attention across news sources so for
example your research might be inquiring
what kind of coverage towns in Greater
Boston are getting or a geographic media
analysis of the Boston Marathon bombings
or an interactive tool that helps media
researchers search for stories with
Geographic dimensions but the challenge
that I wanted to take up for the
culmination of my research here is
around an idea that Ethan Zuckerman
talks about at the end of his book
rewire how can we engineer serendipity
so the very
quick argument for why this is important
is as follows
the internet arrived with a lot of hopes
and dreams for civic engagement and
cosmopolitanism increased access to
information increased tolerance for
diversity global citizenship and today
we do have unprecedented access to
information however researchers like
Ethan and others show us how homophily
the tendency for those for us to group
ourselves with those most like us is
alive and well on the Internet as it is
in physical space this is combined with
greedy corporate data collection and
personalization algorithms that guess
what you want and filter accordingly so
the internet technologies that most
enable our internet our informational
selves powerful search algorithms like
Google social sharing sites like
Facebook or recommendation systems like
Amazon are the ones that reinforce our
homophily through personalization by
giving us what we want what our friends
want and what people like us want so I
want to show you my very small
experiment in this space because it's a
really big you know sort of area of
possibility my project is called terra
incognita 1000 cities of the world and
as a project I'm working on with Matt
stem Peck from the center so it's a
serendipitous global news recommendation
system and game it's based around
exploring news about what we have deemed
the 1,000 most important cities in the
world
it's a extension for the Chrome browser
it's live in the web store now so when a
user opens a new tab in her browser
terra incognita presents her with a map
of one of these thousand cities along
with recommended news stories about that
place so there's a quick tour of the
user interface the main components are
that it shows you a city that you have
not yet ever read about and then there's
a couple of options for interaction
there's the equivalent of the I'm
feeling lucky button and then several
options for scanning news headlines and
looking at news recommendations so it
looks sort of like this for the city of
Xiamen China so you can see that there
are five things to read and those five
things take you to articles from foreign
policy articles from Wikipedia to
government where
sites and an article from Global Voices
about protesters sorry oh my goodness
okay sorry oh my so in any case the one
interesting thing about this project was
that we needed to source many many news
recommendations and we needed them for
the 1,000 cities in the world we source
them from many multiple locations so we
took data from Instapaper from other
users browsing history in the system we
ran a crowdsource campaign we use human
curators and we used live real-time
api's liked bitly we prioritize
alternative and local media news sources
over over mainstream media and even so I
have to say there are huge numbers of
blind spots one of the takeaways from
this project is that it is actually
still really difficult to get
information in English about certain
places in the world so I want to share
with you some of the preliminary user
study results that have come out we
haven't published these quite yet but
what it shows that is that sixty two
point five percent of users show an
increase in geographic diversity of news
reading after installing terra incognita
and a really important kind of secondary
finding is that fifty five percent of
people are actually reading more news in
general just any kind of news doesn't
necessarily have to have a geographic
dimension or not so really encouraging
and interesting results so our next
steps is we do want to kind of complete
the study do another round of
development and talk to all of you about
fun serendipitous ways to engage with
kind of getting outside of ourselves in
terms of finding information so I'd love
to talk further with you all you can
find me in the fall in the Emerson
Department of journalism where I'm gonna
be a professor of civic media and data
visualization and there's my contact
info thanks so much if you are if you
are trying to make your project more fun
you should talk to Katherine I
consistently rely here on her for
suggestions when I have something that
it's too boring and need some help so
next up is Edie Platte who is
essentially my invaluable right-hand at
the Center for civic media so
everybody so every month billions of
people are watching and posting online
videos and they're a great way to
communicate across borders I can post
something now and it can be available
around the world the billions of people
in five minutes so when YouTube posted
lists of the top 10 trending videos per
country per nation for over 50 nations
we got really excited at the Center for
civic media and what grew out of that is
what we watch a collaboration I did with
Rahul Bhargav and Ethan Zuckerman video
was in particularly good good at looking
at culture you can capture things like
music and dance that you can't capture
otherwise so p-squared
video for personally is a there a
Nigerian group but they're doing a
tribute to Michael Jackson an American
pop star videos also great a crossing
boundaries because it can capture
spectacles you can watch a hundred
once-in-a-lifetime events that have been
captured you know one after the other
here's an example of impalas running
from a cheetah jumping into and out of a
tourist car running from through the
windows and if there's been a trend so
not just if someone is watching a video
but if lots of people have watched a
video in a particular geographic region
you know that two things are true
there's some some reason that that video
got in front of all those people and
after they're done watching it they have
a shared common experience now so it's
great for looking at culture most
Americans might not understand the
lyrics to the Korean Gangnam style but
you will see it in the dance clubs here
so one of the things we did was build a
online Explorer that lets you not just
see which videos trend in a particular
area but how videos are connecting
different nations you saw you start with
a map of the world and you can click a
particular nation to see the videos that
are particularly interesting to them and
also a heat map the heat map shows you
how many trending videos they have in
common with other nations around the
world if you click one of those nations
you then see the videos that those two
nations have in common and this can be
really fun if you click two nations that
you think have nothing in common
you'll you'll be surprised to see they
do in fact share things in common and
it's fun to look at what those are if
you want to look at a particular video
like Elvis's the Fox you can see where
around the world that video trended and
how many times and you can also look at
over a range of countries how a video
spreads over time so one one other thing
we looked at was the data what does this
tell us and we looked at 57 countries
over about seven months and the main
thing we saw was a very decentralized
highly connected mesh so every country
pretty much shares at least one video
trend with every other country and it's
it's decentralized the the videos that
two countries share are different from
the videos that to other countries share
so this this shows that there's no
particular there are no particular
trends that our nations here and that
videos are definitely crossing
boundaries but if you zoom in on the
differences interestingly enough you
actually see structures that reflect
pre-existing cultural and geographic
boundaries so you see a large cluster of
the Western world then you see clusters
for the Arab world sub-saharan Africa
Russian Ukraine etc and one thing that
we see here is that countries that are
both central to clusters like Australia
Canada New Zealand have high
migration as do the bridges like the
United Arab Emirates that connects the
Arab world to the rest of the world and
here is the most widely shared video in
our dataset it turns out not to be a
cute cat but a cute baby that was
listening to its mother sing and cycling
through a range of emotions crying
singing crying again and that hit 54
countries in our data set so you can use
this now at what we watch media meter
org and I'm happy to chat with you
either here or on Twitter thank you
[Applause]
so like I said II D and I work together
to support almost all of these projects
so heam didn't valuable in that way in
addition he's also one of the best
people I know at explaining complicated
mathematical concepts in simple terms I
think is he just experienced so that's
incredibly helpful to me so next up we
have Chelsea Baros and Chelsea
hello so I'm gonna share with you a
little bit about my current research for
my master's thesis so in 1987 the New
York Times took a poll asking Americans
if they still believed it was possible
to be born poor to work hard and then
end up rich at the time 57% of Americans
said yes two decades later amidst the
worst financial crisis that we've ever
seen in our lifetimes in my lifetime
that number had actually increased is 72
percent so even though you know our
politics in this country are pretty
polarized it seems like there's one kind
of belief that most Americans still kind
of believe in the belief in the American
meritocracy access educational
opportunity is kind of at the foundation
of this idea however in recent times
we've seen the cost of a college degree
skyrocket while the return on that
investment has steadily diminished um so
yeah today about the average college
graduate graduates with $33,000 of debt
meanwhile unemployment and
underemployment are at all-time highs
what's worse though is that these
hardships aren't evenly distributed
across the population so today
african-american college graduates have
double the unemployment rates of the
rest of their peers who graduate from
college also recent research has shown
that disturbing trends of downwards
mobility for people who graduate from
college who came from the bottom
quintile of the household income bracket
so misses kind of dire background it's
interesting that we've seen a surge in
optimism over the potential for higher
education to be read amah critized with
the rise of the internet and for new
opportunities to emerge for us to access
riches and and and stake out a path for
ourselves so I'm talking about the
stories of the guys who leave college
and pursue of their next big idea and
also teach themselves to code and other
really great skills using the internet
but I'm also talking about the stories
of the underdog the kids from rural and
remote places in the world who are now
able to access resources from some of
the most elite academic institutions in
the world and then get into them at the
heart of this story is really the tech
industry and perhaps rightfully so there
have been groups of programmers and
hackers who've really created a lot of
really vibrant resource
Suzanne online communities for people to
be sharing advice and help each other in
practical and applied problem-solving
this is led for to a lot of leaders
within tack to really describe tack is
kind of the new frontier of meritocracy
in the world however there's been a
growing kind of concern going on about
like the lack of diversity within the
tech sector so as many of you probably
know Google just recently released its
workforce statistics which show that
still largely today the workforce within
tech is largely white largely male which
is kind of showing us that even today is
kind of world of open and free online
resources the protagonists of the
meritocracy story is still kind of the
same as it's always been at the same
time though there's some really
interesting experiments going on right
now specifically within tech trying to
broaden this growing sector to more
accessible for more people
so they're interesting platforms kind of
emerging trying to bet do better
partnerships between people companies
who really want to recruit people with
more marketable skill sets developing
curriculum that is more practical and
applied that people can actually do
while they're actually working full time
as well as organizations that are trying
to develop cohorts for groups that are
right now underrepresented in the sector
trying to create a more vibrant social
support network for people to learn
outside of a formalized classroom
setting so this summer I'm actually
focusing my research on understanding
what are these kind of new and emerging
learning pathways that people are trying
to take in order to actually become
software engineers or web developers
within the tech industry to do this I'm
actually partnering with a recent
recipient of the night news fellow grant
code 2040 I'm gonna be spending the
summer with them and the 27 fellows that
they're bringing to San Francisco and
Silicon Valley and I'm gonna be learning
from them really how are they taking
that first leap of applying what they've
learned to their very first job within
the tech sector these these guys are
really amazing I've already spent three
weeks with them so far and they come
from really a wide range of backgrounds
so some of them are computer science
majors at Stanford and other ones are
working part time and going to Community
College and have really taught
themselves to code
on their own so I'm gonna be working
with them to really understand some of
their experiences as they're learning in
their internships I'm also gonna be
talking to thought leaders and HR
professionals within the field to
understand a little bit more about how
they're thinking about diversity and
their recruitment processes and how
they're thinking about this idea of
meritocracy in their work so here are
some of the key research themes running
out of time got 12 seconds so um you
know the the big the meat of it is
really really wanting to understand how
this ecosystem of higher education is
changing and what are the social and
economic factors that are really shaping
who has accessed to these pathways and
translating those into opportunities in
the future so at a time I would love to
talk about this more Thanks so it's hard
to overstate how much we value this sort
of sociological and anthropology
anthropological focus and lens that the
folks like Chelsea can bring to not only
this project but a variety of projects
so that said we're about to get nerdy so
put on your hats and I'd like to welcome
up sends and I'll lead to speak about
their work avi Hashmi Center for civic
media MIT Media Lab grad student and
sands fish I work at Central Pacific
media and the Berkman Center for
Internet Society so in our world data is
ubiquitous and it is sometimes hard to
make sense of it so it is very much like
this exhibit book from the sky which
remains inaccessible to us without a
narrative so our goal was to provide a
narrative inside for large amounts of
data in contextual frames comprising
keywords this is essentially a discourse
space approach because it treats media
and data as a form of representation our
algorithm essentially treats it as
clusters of it discovers clusters of
topics comprising keywords using a noun
phrase approach and the intuition behind
this is very simple that we can tease
out topical themes through statistical
means
so we're lucky enough to be working with
this amazing platform called media cloud
which has a massive amount of online
news media it's been collecting it for
five or six years now just a really
massive source and a great system that
allows you to basically target a search
use keywords use a date time range and
maybe a particular type of media source
so we've broken things out into
mainstream media left-leaning blogs and
right-leaning blogs and a number of
other categories so you can focus in
your search but what you get even with a
keyword search just like in Google is
just a massive amount of documents so if
you're a citizen journalist if you're a
researcher any of the people that have
access to this system you still have a
really hard time teasing out what the
frames what the conversations are so we
have been running our algorithm on this
to try and tease some of these out on
the NSA and the neutrality controversies
and what you see is even in this really
early work some very clear themes so
this first one that we have here focuses
much more on the government we have
Obama we have policy freedom is in there
and technology a bit so these are not
very very specific frames they're
conversations that are going on that you
use as a starting point for learning
what's going on and how to proceed with
your research the second one we have
here is much more about technology so
you see Internet
let's see neutrality access company data
this is much more the technical frame
this is much more about what the
technology is involved and what this the
vocabulary that people use that are that
are in the know basically for this
particular conversation
the third one stands out a lot more in
terms of what the conversation to the
public is so you can see vocabulary here
that's being used to describe this to
people who are perhaps like lay people
so the big one is Netflix so everybody's
heard this this refrain in the
neutrality debate that says your Netflix
is going to be slow
and this along with some of the other
companies that are up here so you see
Apple you see Google in their subscriber
this is a very distinct conversation
that's going on so essentially the list
will be actually accessible to media
cloud dashboard and Edie and Rahul are
going to talk about that in the next
section we'd love to talk to anybody
that's interested in this so come find
us alright so I'm back with at this time
so our the next presentation is
connected enough that we're gonna jump
right into it so as you heard about the
media cloud platform it's something that
actually was developed by the by the
Berkman Center over at Harvard and of
course Ethan has worked with him for a
long period of time so media cloud has
is this a giant database of news
articles that have been collected for
some of them over 10 years so we have
you know huge amounts of online news
reporting and that's enable the ton of
really fundamental and interesting Media
Studies research and you see these
projects coming out of the Berkman
Center as deep dives along a couple of
dimensions you see things like trying to
understand how the Russian blogosphere
is working so you see things like
understanding the great paper that
Earhart and matt and ethan of course
worked on about understanding how
trayvon martin that story moved from a
local story to something that obama was
commenting on you see a lot of deep sort
of hugely deep dives coming out of this
and that's great and we sort of is made
possible by the database that exists in
media cloud that said it's also a high
burden right that type of research is
very hard to do and the technologies
behind it also sort of have a high
learning curve so after a while we had
enough requests that we said all right
we need to fix this problem this is a
great touch point for us at the Center
for civic media to collaborate with our
friends at Berkman and the fruit of that
collaboration is a platform that we're
calling media meter and media meter is
of course built on top of media cloud
and is a little bit closer to
front-facing tools that people can use
to actually do some of this
search themselves so ed is going to
describe some of what it does and then
I'll tell you about where we're going
with it
all right so media meter is like Rahul
said a suite of tools and a framework
the jumping-off point is something we've
designed called media meter dashboard
and that does two things it allows you
to construct queries it allows you to
say what keywords you're interested in
what date range which media sources if
you want to look at a particular subset
of the media sources and it lets you see
results from widgets that represent all
of the media meter tools all on the same
screen at the same time so you can look
at the same data in many different ways
to see in which ways it's interesting
like I said you can you can query a
single topic you can actually query two
topics to compare as well so I'll jump
in and talk about all of the individual
tools we have three that we've built to
start with the first one is called
mentions
and it very simply looks for mentions of
your subject in the media online and it
tells you where it was mentioned and it
gives you the sentence that was
mentioned in you can unclick that and
read the entire article if you want more
context pulse is built on top of some of
the work from air hartgrave
on a tension plotter and it lets you
track the ebb and flow of mentions the
number of mentions of the subjects
you're interested in over time these
examples are a soccer versus football by
the way this is one of my favorite
examples you can see 52 little bumps so
it's something that everyone talks about
every week except for except for over
the holidays this is actually searching
for it denies in mainstream media
the next widget is called frequency it
it was developed by an undergraduate who
worked with us named Deborah Chen at the
Center for civic media and it lets you
see what other words are mentioned
and when someone is talking about a
particular subject and if you have two
queries it lets you see whether word is
mentioned in both or whether it's
mentioned in one or the other and like I
said this is a framework and we're
currently extending it and a lot of the
work is not just what we've done but
what's coming forward and we're who's
gonna tell you more about that so this
is the dashboard tool is available in
limited beta right now and I think you
are on a second but this is just the
start of sort of the the summer
trajectory into the fall each of these
little widgets that you see here is
going to turn into a full-fledged tool
to help scaffold the media analysis
tasks that that we are sort of trying to
help people do so for instance pulse is
gonna turn into a deeper tool that we've
been calling attention plotter before
where you can integrate other things
like closed caption mentions your own
CSVs and actually dig into us
understanding how the whole media
ecosystem is talking about something
frequency will be a more interactive
tool that you can click around on the
mentions will let you download the list
of stories so you can do your own
research on it so each of those is
getting fleshed out more and we're
extending it over the summer into the
fall as well so the work that Kathryn
did now using have mentioned about cliff
which is a tool we've built for geo
parsing and looking at what a story is
about what place that is actually going
to turn into a tool where you'll be able
to have the same kind of access where
hopefully every story in that database
will be able to tell you what place it's
about and what places are mentioned
there so you could do queries based on
that as well
similarly the great work that you just
heard from ugly and sans is going to be
integrated in some way so that if you
find something really interesting maybe
you can do a topic detection on that and
then get the results and see if that
helps you figure stuff out and like I
said that's the sort of suite that we're
building out so if you're curious about
that and want to try it please hit the
website and sign up to get access right
now it's limited beta because we're
trying to make sure the infrastructure
works before we sort of open it up but
if you get on that waiting list we'll
pull you off of it and come talk to
either edit or myself about it a bit
more thank you very much
so next up that was a little heady a
little bit research focus so next up
we're gonna get something a little more
practical so I'll invite tall up to tell
us about that
thanks for so just a quick show of hands
how many of you are interested in what
the police is doing okay I thought so so
this all started around the Boston
Marathon bombings and I was wondering to
myself I'm a ham radio operator and I
was listening and on the scanners and it
was a lot of information out there there
was obviously reported before the TV
stations reported it but also a lot of
information and nobody reported on and I
was wondering why that happens and I
called up a friend of mine at the Boston
Globe and I said how do you deal with
this hill for information overload how
do you handle all of these channels all
that data and she didn't know how to
answer it but she forward mean another
person who you know how to answer it and
finally I got to the guy that sitting
next to the scanner and he's just alone
there and you know if something happens
he alerts someone but there's no at
least there and in many other news
organizations no kind of proactive
approach to this when something really
big happens they ask for the information
for the police and we'll touch on a
couple of problems with that shortly so
this is what the newsroom looked like in
1940 and this is what looks like today a
lot of differences and this is one of
the tools that reporters used and this
is the tool used today also a lot of
differences this is the police scanner
that was introduced in 1976 and this is
the one use today that's cheaper and
faster but otherwise it lets you listen
to one channel all the time live and
nothing much more than that so the
question is how do we allow access to
this information the primary point of
importance is being aware of what's
happening around you and also ownership
so it's kind of weird that when you want
to investigate the police you have to go
to the police and ask them for these
recordings that when they were live were
public domain
just because nobody's keeping records
some
and some journalists built their own
tools but there's nothing that's really
oriented towards journalists also there
are commercial tools out there the
police is obviously using something to
record the conversations but they are
expensive and you need technicians to
operate them then there's the question
of access so let's say you got the data
the police sent you 17 CDs of channel 1
through 5 hours 1 through 4 channel 5
through 6 hour one through four who have
the time to go through all that data if
you had access the the thesis here is
that if you had access to this
immediately you would utilize it more
and you'd be more effective and you be
able to get more news out of it and then
how do you how do you analyze it once
once you have it it needs to be a group
activity there needs to be collaboration
on this both within the newsroom across
newsrooms in the same network and across
competitors sometimes for example in the
Boston Marathon bombings you could hear
the radio channels here in Boston but
not in New York and the Boston local
outlets could have used help from other
reporters to analyze all this data live
or semi live so the solution is an open
source hardware and software platform
that very cheaply allows to create a
TiVo like mechanism that lets the
newsroom first of all record everything
at the first stage that's what working
on now
second of all allow for a collaboration
on the analysis of the data and in the
future to transcribe it and allow to
search not only by channel and time but
also other types of analytics how often
does the Boston Police say 15 Main
Street and when is the last time they
said 15 Main Street and why for example
let me show you a quick overview of what
we have now
it's an overly engineered display but
just to give a proof of concept and to
help you understand a little bit of
behind the scenes and where this might
go also we are looking for people to
collaborate on this if your newsroom is
interested in exploring this talk to us
we want to be want to make sure this
tool gets used and help students
actually get their work done if we build
this in a way that requires a new
employee to sit down next to this tool
obviously nobody's going to use it so
we're trying to learn how you access the
scanner today and how we can replace it
so really quickly
is from the lab this is what a single
channel looks like this is in lab
conditions this is my daughter's baby
monitor and so the the horizontal axis
is frequencies and the vertical axis is
time and you can see that she coughed
five times and then twice later on this
is what it looks like in real life these
are police channels you can see that
there's chatter on four channels and
really quick call on another Channel
imagine what happens right now is you're
living at the top bar and you're hearing
live and if you're listening to one
channel you're definitely missing
another when you see this and obviously
we need to make it a display that's
that's that's a quest the answer we need
from you guys what should it look like
if you see this and imagine you can
click on any point in time 30 minutes
ago an hour ago and listen to what
happened there and then just that I
think would be a great tool looking
forward to hearing from you guys thank
you very much so that's a great example
of some of the things that we can try to
do to actually work on the real problems
that some of the folks in this room are
struggling with one of the other
pleasures that I have is working with
all these folks that have talents in a
lot of different domains so for instance
Ollie is actually well trained is both a
computer scientist and a journalist so
he and Julia are gonna come up and speak
about one of the more journalism project
focused projects they've been working on
hello hi everyone so I'm Julia Blues I'm
a health reporter and night science
journalism fellow here at MIT Ali Hashmi
Center for civic media um so today we're
talking about this question can big data
save health journalism so the problem as
you all probably know health reporters
like me we don't always do a great job
of reflecting science or the things that
actually I impact Public Health you've
seen the stories on chocolate and wine
and coffee they're your friends one week
and your foes the next week but what do
you think what actually kills Americans
so you in the audience tell me what do
you think of the top causes of mortality
in America anything else
heart disease okay we have a smart
audience today so according to the
latest CDC figures it's cancer heart
disease and chronic respiratory diseases
like emphysema and bronchitis but how
does it how are these things actually
reported in the media so Ali and I just
did this quick search of the New York
Times for the keyword cancer health
stories in the last 12 months 4,200
mentioned so cancers mentioned a lot but
emphysema one of the key chronic
respiratory center conditions that are
one of the leading causes of death in
America for results in the last year so
we started to think as journalists could
we use this data in a way that might
actually help reporters see these gaps
and blind spots in their coverage or see
places that they might pay more
attention to and issues that my issues
of health that might actually matter to
their audiences so Ellie and I created
this the health gap it's a prototype now
that we're building and you can see on
the top from the scroll down menu you
can choose diseases and then you the the
mortality and the populations visualized
and the mentions in the New York Times
are visualized as well and you can see
very clearly that there's a gap for
example between chronic lower
respiratory diseases and then the little
tiny number of stories that are
mentioned in the New York Times about
chronic respiratory conditions
and so we have found similar trends and
other countries as well here is an
example from India where we're actually
looking at disease burden and neonatal
diseases which have a huge disease
burden in India are not adequately
covered in their leading newspaper Times
of India we are using sources like media
cloud LexisNexis and other big data
sources to to actually consolidate data
across different media sources and but
we want to build up from here we're
ambitious people we think that there's a
lot of opportunity to gather different
types of data and help maybe inform
journalists and editors on and kind of
help them see where there might be again
these blind spots and gaps so we want to
expand the focus beyond the countries
that we're looking at now we only had
data from the leading newspapers in
India Canada in the US but we hope to
include other countries we hope to add
more media outlets and most importantly
we want to create a feature that makes
this tool interactive so that reporters
and journalists from any news outlet can
download their data and then compare it
to key indicators like mortality Daly's
disability adjusted life years which are
the disease burden in the population and
other things like one thing that would
be really interesting would be getting
research investments so public kind of
seeing where there's gaps between where
a population is investing its resources
in research and then where journalists
might be missing opportunities to report
on that research that their citizens are
investing in anyway so that's where
we're going with this and right now you
can see the latest version at health gap
Brown Bag dot me and please keep in
touch and send us any of your comments
or questions at our contact info there
thanks so much
[Applause]
[Music]
Thanks so that's one of the sort of a
handful of examples you've seen around
taking the data that we've been able to
acquire in lots of different places or
create and driving action in this case
journalists action so the the next
weaker William Lee is also another
example of using data to derive some
action William okay thanks for a whole
good morning my name is William Lee and
I'm a PhD student in computer science
here at MIT I want to talk to you today
about a particular project build tracer
that came out of Ethan's class on the
future of news and civic media and some
thoughts on analyzing open government
data so this is part of page one of 848
pages of the dodd-frank Wall Street
Reform and Consumer Protection Act and
as smart as this audience is it's
probably the case that most of us did
not read all eight hundred and forty
eight pages so can we use some kind of
data science machine learning text
analysis to help us understand
government systems and processes and
that's what I want to walk you through
today so this is another bill related to
the financial crisis the Troubled Asset
Relief Program or tarp this was passed
on October 3rd 2008 after the collapse
of AIG to bail out the banks with 700
billion dollars and what I've done here
is I've represented each of the 39
sections of this bill just as dots just
the text of those sections and what I
can do then is I can start to trace back
to all the bills introduced in this
particular Congress and see what was
introduced and every time there's a
matches sufficiently matching section of
text in another bill I'll make another
dot as well and so we can start to walk
backwards
you might recall there was a failed
House vote in the failed vote in the
House of Representatives and the Dow
Jones dropped 780 points this was what
was included in that bill and I can keep
tracing back all the way and sort of see
what was included in this particular
bill and then we can look at it and see
what was included finally what got into
tarp so what you can see here is there
was a energy bill that sort of got in
there was a stalled alternative minimum
tax bill that got into tar
as well and finally the reauthorization
of the secure rural schools and
community self-determination Act of 2002
get enough votes for for tarp or the
emergency economic stabilization Act to
pass and so we can do the same thing
then for other bills say related to the
financial crisis in some cases bills
have lots of new content content so in
the stimulus bill after a new
presidential administration perhaps not
surprisingly most the content is new
except something about electronic health
records this is the housing and economic
Recovery Act where the federal
government took over Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac and you can see what these
rates some of these regulations were
considered for fairly long periods of
time and returning to dodd-frank
this is dodd-frank so here you can see
there are student regulations related to
swaps through the antitrust savings
clause and gives us a sense of what was
considered in Congress and for what
periods of time as a small mini
extension of this it's possible to look
forward in time and take a look at say a
bill that was passed maybe by the House
or the Senate
but didn't make it to the President's
desk and this is one particular bill in
2007 you can see what parts got into the
Housing and Economic Recovery Act and in
general I'm interested in extending
backward and forward in Congress
multiple congresses or even into things
like model legislation or white papers
or policy papers to really see where
bill ideas are made where bill ideas or
policy ideas are born so I wanted to
spend the last couple of minutes just
telling you a little bit of what I hope
to work on I'm really hoping to get your
feedback on the rest of the day today or
else we're in touch so in government
data in the beginning there were all
these PDFs or maybe before that
government started to put data online
but it was difficult to parse difficult
to understand and then as a results of a
lot of efforts of journalists and open
government and advocates and civic
hackers and open source projects a lot
of leaders of whom are in this room
there's been a lot of success in
obtaining cleaning parsing structuring
government data as a small tangent I
think for me as a PhD student in
computer science there's an opportunity
to work on what I'm calling automatic
structure recovery possible
to help with this process but beyond
that now that this data is available now
that this data is open there's
potentially new opportunities for new
kinds of data science type analyses and
visualizations for understanding
government whether it's things like
tracing the trajectory of policies in
Congress with this bill tracer project
or things like perhaps mapping the cross
citation structure in the United States
code or another project we worked on
last year to try to unmask the
authorship of unsigned per curiam
Supreme Court opinions so these are some
things that might be possible with the
data available today
I'd be very interested in continuing the
discussion with you thanks very much for
your time this stuff is so cool I had
like 50 ideas already and we still have
three speakers left so next up I'd like
to invite you wank not only I've learned
a ton about the Chinese context but also
I'm just consistently impressed by his
ability to get stuff done you hello
everybody I will spend some time
introducing how crowdsourcing works in
our project the NGO 12 project we works
with Chinese NGOs all nonprofit
organizations and we prize solutions to
their communication ease technology
needs and resource needs
today I will showcase two of these ten
projects under this umbrella our cost my
map and the field guide to software's
for NGOs this is our map in this map
every NGO can register on the map and
publish their events or projects or
update their information and they can
also find cooperation with social
responsibility information and best
practice practices of cooperation and
NGO partnerships the interesting thing
is that when NGO first used our math at
the very first time
they start to locate themselves within
the map and see what's happening in
their surroundings one NGO from Hunan
Province from the phone last there is
exactly another NGO just just in their
next door working in the same area but
they have never heard of that before so
this man may provide opportunities for
participation or collaboration or at
least NGOs know each other and not only
NGOs can find other NGOs NGOs can also
find corporations for potential fundings
and corporations can find NGOs if they
want to do some corporate social
responsibility work and the small
companies they can search for the big
players such as China Mobile to find
what they are doing with social
responsibility and in the current
version of the map we allow NGOs to mark
their collaborative relationships in the
map so they can see a nice graph showing
their impact or influence in this
country and another thing is our
workshop we this is our tenth workshop
on web 2.0 technologies for Chinese and
years held in guido province and jean
this is our curriculum we teach them how
to build social media strategies and how
to use the information communication
technologies and how to use cloud-based
tools for their organizational
management and in the last part we have
our nonprofit toolbox this toolbox or
the field guides for softwares to NGOs
is a cross platform that everybody can
write a piece of article about software
which could be used by the NGOs for
nonprofit use currently it has more than
130 articles in that and during the
workshop we asked our participants to
select maximum of
articles to build their own tool sets
that suit aful the most useful for their
own knees here is the result of what one
organization did they picked up these
five tools for their use they include
one knows Microsoft one knows for
collaborative note-taking and why that's
interesting because it's a voice
communication platform initially used by
the online gamers in such as Warcraft
but the NGO started to use that for the
team training something like that and
Mike CRM that's a free online customer
relationship management tool to manage
their volunteers and founders and the V
chat it's a mobile app to you know to
communicate within a group and finally
our NGO math so this is how the cross
out cross salting works with us and you
can follow out our Twitter or ask
questions so I can answer you or if you
have Weibo account you can also follow
that thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
so next up I want to invite advice who
is working on the MIDI on project which
I think not only myself but a lot of
other folks in this room are following
thanks Russ hey everybody I am advice I
work at me Dan with a bunch of really
remarkable people in San Francisco
Vancouver Cairo to son Brazil most other
corners of the world as well we're
thrilled to be a prototype Award winner
for our Czech desk project I'm not going
to talk to you about Czech desk today
though I'm going to talk to you about a
really fascinating project that like
many of the fascinating and wonderful
things in my life is downstream of an
email from Ethan so I have to
acknowledge that Paul Salopek is a
Pulitzer Prize winning journalist who is
I mean in in in this era of the the
five-minute half-life of a tweet we're
doing a digital project with Paul that
spans seven years and traces a
twenty-one thousand mile arc around the
world Paul is literally walking the path
of human migration and and this will
take seven years he'll cover 21,000
miles and me Deanna's along for the ride
we are following Paul and every 100
miles along this route
Paul is filing a dispatch when Paul
files his dispatches he's sometimes
stopping in some of the most remote and
desolate places in the world turns out
that much of the world is empty and
desolate but along the way almost
everyone he encounters is connected to
the Internet necessary satellite phones
or mobile devices along the way there is
is a parallel conversation that's that's
this happening on the Internet
so we are aggregating curating and
trance
these thin sections through the global
social media so imagine imagine this as
you know modern archaeology we're taking
100 mile samples around the path of
human migration so how are we doing this
first we're working with Todd MA stack
and and map D to geo bound and
temporally bound an initial data set of
social media so the the workflow is on
gets a message from Paul or Patrick and
ends they say okay what yours here's the
lat/long of our next Coordination of
where we're gonna be in two days we then
and have built this data set and then
like any good scrappy nonprofit we
figure that well we should make use of
tools we already have so we hacked the
check desk platform you see here's
here's check desk which is basically an
annotation framework that allows
journalists to create a change log
verifying social media so we're using
this to create translations and create
an embeddable object with those
translations and we're also using it to
we hacked it to create some translation
notes you can see here the the content
the translation and then translation
notes that provide some context so it's
it's the the resulting we sort from
10,000 pieces of social media down to 50
or 100 translate those and the the kind
of editorial prerogative is is anything
that's poignant mundane inspiring you
know it or you know trivial that's
anything we just want to provide what we
think is a thin section across this
these sample points so why are we doing
this big picture I'm gonna I'm gonna
provide some backwards context and then
some forward context this is Mona safes
book page it's really important if you
want to understand Egypt you should be
able to understand this Facebook page
and Mona's brother is the bloggers and
technologist Allah so you you see your
profile picture here three jailed
Egyptian activists can't read it we've
been working at me dance since I think
the first social media translation
project that we did was 2008 and and
here's a and then 2009 we did a Farsi
translation project translating tweets I
mean the so poetic we place our feet in
our own step own footsteps and we set
like the Sun this was in in Farsi would
never have been never would have reached
outside that language community we also
did a lot of work around the obviously
around Arab Spring having an office in
Cairo whole project started with
partnership with IBM Foundation we
created one of the first cross lingual
websites way back in the day so where
we're headed with this project the
forward context so a seven-year project
National Geographic is supporting Paul
in his walk were we're bringing in
resource behind the technical side of
this seven years gives us I think I
think where the web's going to be in
seven years
as Paul traces this arc of human
migration we're going to trace this arc
of creating the cross lingual web and
and this this is I want to close with
this and then I want to read a tweet
that's gonna be sent about something
that I said so that I'll actually say it
so it can be accurately tweeted this is
a beautiful quote and and it goes to the
heart of the you know what we've been
talking about over these last two days
which is the the importance of the
connected web this was translated by my
colleague Anika
at Anna's and and the that there there
is a parallel that we haven't talked
about at all in these two days and the
parallel is language language is just as
important as connectivity language is an
access issue if it were isolated the
world wide web is a thousand siloed webs
right now and it won't be open until
translation is baked into the structure
of the web so we need to work with
Facebook we need to work with Twitter we
need to work with Mozilla to bake this
in so that communities can collaborate
to translate important content thanks
very much
[Applause]
great so last step we have den Harlow
and Allyson talking about the amazing
hackathon that happened right before the
conference started so yeah hi I'm Dan
sinker I'm the director of the night
Mozilla open news project we're helping
to build and strengthen the community
that is coding in and around journalism
and one of the things we've done for the
last three years in advance of this
conference thanks to the support of the
center and the knight foundation is run
a hack weekend two days Saturday and
Sunday we grab folks that are going to
be coming to the conference and we give
them the opportunity to to build and
collaborate together this year we had
six really great teams and I wanted to
just give Alison hurt and harlow Holmes
a chance to talk about two of the
projects that came out of this weekend's
hack weekend
hi I'm Alison
and so when Russia annexed Crimea there
was a bit of discussion of force in the
news about how on the Russian version of
Google Maps boo cold are you they sell a
version of the map that showed a very
solid line separating Ukraine from
Crimea indicating like you know Russia
owns this now but other versions of the
map like the US version of the map or
the Ukrainian version the map should
actually a dotted line showing kind of
more more of a dispute so for this hack
day we're looking kind of exploring that
and looking at other possible other
disputed territories so we started with
a data set of disputed territories
around the world narrow that down to
ones that actually should something
interesting on different versions of
Google Maps and built a site so here are
a couple examples where you see it most
often I mean most of the time disputed
areas are just represented a dotted
lines across like all the versions of
Google Maps that we were seeing but
particularly in cases of like India
China Russia where there were disputes
the Chinese version might be totally
different from the Indian version and
not really necessarily reflecting you
know sort of the dotted line that this
is a dispute solid line this is this is
our view of fact don't like you know our
version of the facts it's kind of
fascinating I mean granted I'm coming
from a you know a u.s. perspective and
like Google Maps is from a u.s.
perspective you know kind of the the
notion that kind of what is fact is kind
of different depending on where you're
at and it's kind of enclosing I when one
thing is kind of fascinating looking at
the Google version or the Chinese
version of Google Maps is there's this
dotted line they're kind of like a very
solid line of Google's word of China's
borders but also a dotted line I'm going
down like down past the Philippines and
around Taiwan and not definitely sort of
like you know this is art and kind of
declaring ownership which is just kind
of fascinating anyway a project URLs
here and the code is up on github
[Applause]
hi I'm Harlow I'm gonna tell you about a
project that we did it's called Keebler
we built an ad-hoc Network big whoop
right however this is actually a story
about remediation and so I'm going to
talk about something that inspired me to
to do this um back in the aughts there's
a technology that was called wizzy
digital courier it came out of South
Africa and parts of Zimbabwe and its
purpose was to connect schools when the
internet went down with a capital I as
it often did and the way that it did was
by there was a router in a truck the
truck would drive up to a school the
school knew how to associate to the
router it would put all of its email and
you know extra data onto it the router
then would send the school's Network you
know the email and correspondence that
was for it drive off to another school
lather rinse repeat and this was
actually a really really great way of
shuttling around information when the
grid went down so we decided to use the
goal was how can we creatively using
tools at our disposal remediates such a
network so Keibler's actually if you
hear a play on words if you can imagine
a router like this that like sits up in
a tree but like they're like all these
elves inside that are actually you know
passing your data around so it yeah back
to remediation on this box is a piece of
really awesome software called open wrt
open wart which is pretty much a UNIX OS
for a router and what we did then was we
actually combined that with the idea of
a bulletin board so you know how there's
public messages all of the messages are
encrypted maybe if you know Adam Langley
from Google's project called pond this
might sound familiar to you some of them
at all the messages are encrypted the
ones that are for you you get the ones
that you aren't for you well you can't
really do anything with them and then we
threw a third thing on top of that which
was get well SVN or whatever and
actually via other packages that allowed
for syncing instantaneously so all of
the stuff that was on you know the in
the
posit Ori was shared immediately in
synced between mobile clients that were
connected to our network this was really
really fun and really easy to do here's
the team the five of us here are current
or former Knight Mozilla fellows however
I want to give out a shot up to Hazen
who is a interloper a independent
journalist from Turkey who while she was
not a coder looked at exactly how easily
we mobilized and put together this
project in such little time and thought
you know I could bring this home and
just with a little knowledge we can just
share the knowledge of how easy
something like this can be thank you so
awesome now that your brains are full
thanks very much and Ethan's gonna bring
us to a close wait a second don't go
anywhere
I first of all can we get a round of
applause for the amazing folks who just
presented during this look this job that
I have here is about as much fun as you
can have and be employed by an academic
institution and it's because we get to
work with people like this all the time
it's absolutely wonderful and as rahul
has been really good about saying on
this you've got the opportunity to work
with them as well everybody who
presented here needs help on these
projects and needs help on trying to
bring them further
please find people over lunch after the
conference push things further let's
also get a round of applause for the guy
who not only put this session together
but has a hand in something like 80% of
those projects rahul Bhargav who's just
done an incredible job of really kicking
into an extra gear the research we're
doing here I couldn't do this job
without him it's amazing to have the
chance to work with him everybody we've
got